[Música]
mas ela é tão inteligente
essa foi a frase que eu escutei as
pessoas falarem dos meus pais quando eu
reprovei de ano
essa foi a vez que eu entendi que as
coisas que importavam pra mim de verdade
nunca iam ser medidas nas notas das
provas
eu vi uma criança curiosa bem
comunicativa e eu tinha bastante
facilidade prendendo inventar
brincadeiras novas com gente diferente
de mim eu gostava bastante de brincar
lugares novos lugares que não tinha ido
antes e por isso foi muito bom ter
crescido com o irmão mais ou menos da
mesma idade e o que a gente gostava
mesmo de fazer era explorar coisas novas
perto da gente a gente gostava muito de
acampar no jardim por exemplo no jardim
de casa então era dormir fora né a gente
tem que preparar nossa mochila aquele
kit de sobrevivência e sair de casa e
explorar o que fosse né
e naquele trajeto de uns dez passos mais
ou menos até a barraca da casa até a
barraca a gente conseguia escutar gritos
lulu coruja
tinha até um coral de sapos lá em casa
que ainda tem porque é muito fácil
perceber como eles cantam diferentes mas
que têm aquela sintonia entre eles a
gente gostava muito de prestar atenção
nas coisas que aconteciam em volta da
gente
até numa tentativa de começar a entender
melhor como que as plantas cresciam e
como que tudo funcionava de natureza
a gente fez uma horta colocou umas
moedinhas de alface viu crescia
funcionava e foi vender os vizinhos
nessa época que a gente tinha 17 ou 18
anos
a gente entendeu como as plantas
cresciam e o que a gente queria mesmo
era entender o nosso entorno
depois disso o meu irmão começou a ter
interesse por desmontar os brinquedos
entender como eles funcionavam por
dentro e aí eu comecei a sentar do lado
dele fazer companhia mas eu comecei a
ler eu pegava livros ele histórias que
me levavam para outros lugares super
diferentes e as histórias que eu não lia
eu comecei a inventar
comecei a gostar muito de escrever
fui crescendo lendo muito e não
começaram os livros né
mas nessa época estava vindo a internet
passou a ser um ritual sentar na frente
do computador entrar na internet
aquele mundo à parte e de repente aquela
tela e me mostrar lugares que nunca
tinha ido gente que eu nunca tinha visto
antes e histórias que tinha acontecido
mas não era nem no meu colégio nem na
minha rua
naquele momento eu vi que junta a minha
curiosidade uma ferramenta tão
exponencial como a internet abriu meus
horizontes de uma forma que já não tinha
mais conserto
eu tinha 16 anos quando eu reprovei de
ano
e foi nesse ano também que foi morar
fora pela primeira vez
primeiro queria entender um pouco mais
essa coisa de origens da família de onde
a gente vem e tal
se me levou a uma cidade no interior da
alemanha onde eu morei por um tempo e eu
entendi o privilégio que é poder morar
num lugar seguro e tranqüilo
depois disso eu fui morar na turquia
e aí eu já era um pouco mais velha
estava estudando arquitetura e eu acho
que justamente pela idade já é um pouco
mais velha as experiências de
voluntariado teve um impacto bem grande
pra mim quando eu cheguei na turquia o
que eu entendi era que aqueles anos de
estudar inglês e alemão que eu tinha
feito no colégio e de tarde nos outros
horários
não tinha me preparado para me comunicar
com aquela cultura
depois eu entendi que aquelas horas que
tinha passado na prancheta desenhando
tentando fazer maquete para mostrar os
meus projetos as minhas ideias
aquilo não tinha ensinado porque vinha
uma uma canção cinco vezes por dia das
mesquitas e aquela viagem que fiz pra
disney com os meus pais ninguém falou
pra mim naquele dia porque queria ter
que cobrir a cabeça com um lenço quando
eu entrar sem espaços sagrados
eu acho que não demorou 24 horas por dia
na turquia a entender que se eu quisesse
cumprir o que estava lá pra fazer que
era da aula de inglês para crianças com
síndrome de down durante os próximos
três meses o que eu tinha que fazer com
tudo o que eu achava que eu sabia até
ali nos meus nem 20 anos né
era deixar aquilo pra trás e encarar
aquilo que mais curiosidade entendeu
entorno em que eu estava
e aí o que eu percebi foi que está neste
estado de não saber me tornou muito mais
capaz de absorver conhecimento de
aprender muito mais e não só de entender
o que eu tinha para oferecer àquelas
pessoas que contavam comigo mas também
de sentir o que elas queriam eu cheguei
na turquia munida de preparação cultural
estava toda pronta cheia de informação
eu cheguei lá e abre uma portinha de uma
coisa que eu não conhecia e aí já não
era mais sobre a diferença cultural
entre o brasil ea turquia aquilo era uma
viagem uma jornada minha se ser criativo
essa habilidade que as pessoas têm de
conectar pontos
para mim ser curioso é identificar e
reconhecer esses pontos que a gente vai
ligar depois então eu entendo que quando
a gente amplia os nossos horizontes a
gente está ampliando essa quantidade de
pontos que pode conectar depois a gente
está se expondo a coisas diferentes do
que a gente está acostumado e cada vez é
mais freqüente ou mais passeio a gente
encontrar pessoas que são especialistas
em uma área
é mais gente que está disposta a ficar
fora da sua zona de conforto se
desafiando a fazer links conexões e
vendo oportunidades em coisas culturas
espaços lugares gente diferente essas
pessoas são cada vez mais raras
essas pessoas são as pessoas generalista
e generalista não quer só dizer que eles
ampliam o leque dos interesses que eles
têm mas que na mesma proporção ele se
aprofundam naquele conhecimento a gente
é isso que a gente tem visto mais
pessoas especialistas hoje em dia isso é
uma coisa nova porque se a gente for
olhar para trás quando as pessoas não é
como não era muita gente que tinha
acesso a estudar eles não iam à não se
eu vou estudar então vou ficar só nessa
área aqui ele se envolviam em outras
coisas misturavam temas diferentes
é como por exemplo a gente lembrar que a
pessoa que tem a mesma pessoa que teve a
sensibilidade pra pintar a monalisa teve
todo um conhecimento e técnica de
engenharia para criar o helicóptero que
foi confecionada 20 durante muito tempo
tem interesse por áreas diferentes era
visto como errado
falta de foco alguma coisa assim e eu
pensei isso durante muito tempo que era
errado eu gostar de coisas distintas
querer fazer essas misturas e achar que
tinha tudo a ver na verdade e quando eu
entendi o potencial que isso tinha que
eu passava por temas diferentes me
expunha a temas distintos
eu entendi que era justamente essa
capacidade de fazer conexões e continuar
eu mesma
quero o meu maior diferencial mas a
gente fala de curiosidade que aparecendo
muito bonito muito fácil mas na verdade
que curiosidade assim como a
criatividade é o músculo que a gente
precisa treinar e incentivar e no trio
eu tenho um amigo que conta uma história
que quando ele era pequeno
a mãe dele acende uma vela do lado dele
falava para o dia que o fogo vai com a
novela paga hoje a cientista
e eu tenho certeza que ele passou todos
os dias da vida dele
nutrindo esse músculo ou treinando esse
músculo da curiosidade e aí fui pensando
poder que a gente tem como mulher de
poder influenciar tanto na forma como os
nossos filhos vão ver o mundo
transformando ele 100 pessoas super
curiosas carregando um monte de
perguntas o tempo todo entre um
aprendizado e outro ser curioso é muito
mais do que perguntar o porquê das
coisas e sempre quando a gente é pequeno
né tem um vocabulário mais limitado mas
é curioso pode ser perguntar quando como
quem
mas mais que isso
entender que nunca vai ter uma resposta
que vai satisfazer aquela curiosidade de
saber um pouco mais se a curiosidade é
um músculo a ser treinado estimulado
cabe a cada um de nós entender como que
a gente vai manter o nosso então eu
sempre gostei de histórias e
particularmente eu tenho muita
curiosidade entender as histórias das
pessoas
isso foi o meu jeito que eu encontrei de
manter a minha curiosidade viva
então as pessoas que passaram pela minha
vida ou que passam ainda eu aprendi
muito com elas eu vivi com elas eu vivi
as histórias delas e eu acho que várias
dessas histórias fazem parte hoje de
quem eu sou
por exemplo essa experiência na turquia
quando estava morando lá e estava
hospedada na casa de uma mulher que
tinha perdido o filho e com três anos
afogado numa piscina e o que ela eo
marido fizeram foi transformador disso
na oportunidade de diminuir um pouquinho
a dor do próximo eles criaram um centro
de educação pra crianças especiais
depois disso eu fui pra áfrica do sul e
eu tive uma oportunidade incrível de
poder falar sobre privilégios com um
grupo de pessoas que chacoalhou
completamente o meu jeito de ver o mundo
depois disso eu fui voluntária por
exemplo num no berçário de um orfanato e
eu nunca tinha percebido com o poderoso
pode ser a gente dá colo
eu ainda tinha um pouco pendentes a
curiosidade pela escrita foi explorar um
pouco mais e acabei juntando um grupo de
pessoas ea gente aprendeu com o poderoso
podia ser papel e caneta para falar dos
temas que a gente acha mais difícil pôr
para fora ou só para curtir as boas
doses da vida também pode ser tentado
uma mesa explorando sobre
sustentabilidade eu percebi que a
empatia pode ser também pelas gerações
que ainda vão vir ou pela natura
natureza o lugar onde a gente mora na
suíça eu tive oportunidade de facilitar
um workshop para repor
os sírios e ali eu aprendi que muitas
vezes a coisa mais importante que a
gente tem para fazer é agradecer por
estar vivo e entender o valor que têm
uma segunda chance pra gente poder
recomeçar
eu ouvi um monte de histórias
eu adoro ouvir histórias muitas vezes é
difícil imaginar que essas histórias
aconteceram de verdade passou a ser
impossível ficar alheia ao que era
conversar comigo que era compartilhado
o que eu entendi é que a curiosidade não
tem que ser uma coisa egoísta porque
acaba na gente mesmo
ela pode e deve ser compartilhada com o
mundo pode se transformar em projetos
incríveis para o mundo
então eu deixo para vocês uma reflexão
de como vocês têm usado a curiosidade de
vocês pra trazer algo bom para o mundo o
que a gente é na verdade é como se fosse
uma colcha de retalhos enorme a gente é
uma coleção de coisas a gente as músicas
que a gente escuta os livros que a gente
lê os amigos que a gente tem as
conversas que a gente tem com eles os
lugares que a gente visita hoje que a
gente já visitou os que quer visitar a
gente essa combinação de coisas
e quando a gente é curioso que a gente
faz é que a gente amplia tudo isso
tornando muito mais fácil a gente
encontrar nossa essência de verdade e
quando a gente consegue expressar o que
a gente realmente é
fica muito mais fácil para as pessoas se
conectarem contigo criando mais empatia
e muitas vezes mais confiança
se eu falasse para aquela ana que
reprovou no ensino médio e achou que
aquilo era o fim do mundo
quero encontrar justamente um lugar que
é no trio as habilidade dela de se
conectar com gente diferente que ela ia
morar em mais sete países e que um dia
ela acha que física é assim
fascinante eu sei que ela vai acreditar
naquela ana que reprovou mas aprendeu a
viver de um jeito curioso mesmo que isso
não fosse nem medida e nem aprovado pelo
colégio
o meu muito obrigado
[Aplausos]